think they'll subtitle it the happiest
streaming on earth so you were probably
expecting a game of Thrones review for
the season 8 premiere that recently
happened thing is though I've realized
as Sunday wore on I was not gonna be
coherent enough by that late I've I'm
beaten up I need to get a decent night's
sleep and I can work I was planning to
do this anyway I record this earlier
will do Game of Thrones tomorrow so
right now I'm gonna talk instead about
Disney plus the Disney streaming service
that I've mentioned in passing with
other stuff before but I kind of want to
dig into a little bit deeper because
they've announced a whole mess of stuff
in it and they are pushing hard I
haven't done a video on this but he came
up in like a streaming and I've talked
about it like on the on the discord it's
a patreon exclusive perk so you know if
you want to get in on it that's how you
do it hey
awkward plug so like I mentioned with
Apple's whole streaming thing how half
assed that feels it feels very it feels
very much like Apple going well we're
not doing that yet so I guess we'll do
that too whereas Disney really feels
like a full-court press they are putting
not only a lot of effort a lot of names
a lot of talent I'd no doubt a lot of
money but also a surprising amount of
prestige behind this because obviously
Disney and this I have mentioned before
Disney is one of the few conglomerates
because of of the fact I mean well
honestly even before they bought
everybody even before that they were one
of the few you know entities with a
extensive enough catalog of really well
regarded films and TV series to be able
to justify having their own exclusive
thing like when
yes launched it's streaming you know it
it's one thing you know to launch it
with Star Trek and you know I'm not
gonna lie I kind of wish I could see the
the new Twilight Zone but like I'm not
gonna get a whole new streaming service
just to see that but you know that that
was puzzling to me CW has seed which I
keep forgetting is a thing that exists
but like Disney's got a lot and when you
start taking you to account all the
stuff that they bought recently that
means they've also got you know all the
Marvel movies all the Star Wars stuff
including the TV shows all of Fox
including the entire run of The Simpsons
which they're putting up I on that on
launch so like this is a heavy catalog
and it's on its own that could possibly
justify and they are pricing
aggressively they are they're severely
coming in under you know very
deliberately coming under what Netflix
charges on a monthly basis um I have no
doubt that that price will eventually go
up it'll probably be a number of years
but like this is them making their stamp
on the market and business-wise it makes
a lot of sense I I do want to talk a
little bit more about the potential for
the creative end of it though we are
learning little bits and pieces about
the Star Wars series that's gonna get
launched the Mandalorian I want to see a
trailer on that just cuz I'm I I'm in a
place where like I'm skeptical of Star
Wars I'm not proud of that
like I'm real I'm not that that's just
where I'm at but something like the
Marvel stuff I'm actually legitimately
kind of curious on what they're gonna do
especially when you compare what Marvel
TV has been up to this point because up
to this point Marvel TV was agents of
shield agent Carter V Inhumans and then
the Netflix stuff and you know there
have been a handful of other things on
sporadic other services I can't remember
if cloak and dagger has actually come
out or if we're still waiting on that I
can't remember now there's the runaways
that's on Hulu but the the these
things they've just kind of been there
so like I remember initially when Ages
of shields launched there was like this
big clamor within the phantom of like oh
wow there's gonna be a TV show that ties
into the movies and all this stuff and
like technically it did but you're not
much like just in tiny nods now part of
that was for a stupid behind the scenes
reason the guy who runs the TV division
does not get along with Kevin Feige who
runs the movies but I don't know if like
if they've managed to put their
differences aside or if they found an
intermediary or something but there's
some big moves being done so we already
know that they are making a animated
what-if series which is a fantastic
concept and they have announced Scarlet
Witch envisioned combine the show and
there's gonna be a Hawkeye show about
him passing the the mantle of Hawkeye to
Kate Bishop who in the comics sort of
took over the mantle from him there's
gonna be a Loki series no he's not
coming back to life he is in fact dead
it's a prequel for him you know when he
was being the mischievous God and just
creating havoc and all of these are
going to be starring the stars from the
movies and I'm pretty sure there's one
or two that I've forgotten but like
that's that's a big deal because the
thing is these movie actors in in good
places with their careers don't do more
than like the occasional TV guest spot
by and large they don't like getting
roped into those kinds of contracts is
usually the big thing now most of these
are probably going to be limited series
you know one season maybe two shorter
like six days six to ten episodes
kind of thing but this is a much more
tight integration of with the rest of
the MCU now will storylines actually
crossover with the MCU probably not
probably not very much at any rate I
wouldn't expect them to just because the
logistics of trying to keep that all
straight because
a really big mess and then you also have
to be really careful about what you put
in the movies because you don't want it
to be a situation where people won't
understand the movies if they haven't
also been watching the TV shows because
the simple reality is more people go to
these movies than see these TV shows so
you can't really do that so the level of
integration was always a little bit of
smoke and mirrors in the first place
because logistically they were never
gonna be a slightly integrated as fans
kind of wanted them to be just because
it's not realistic but to actually have
the stars from the movies in these shows
on this streaming service that's
aggressive well and and to the best of
my knowledge obviously contracts are
usually not made public but to the best
of my knowledge TV appearances were not
part of the original contracts for these
actors for the films you know they had
multi-picture deals and some of them
were on the hook for like you know 10
films not necessarily where they're the
lead but like to appear in in some
capacity but like TV was not or at least
no one ever indicated that that was part
of their contracts and yet here they are
so I'm pretty sure these folks were
really well paid to be doing this it's
it is it is a big big move and I think
especially compared with something like
say the Netflix stuff which did try and
interconnect the shows that it had but
like never really tied them into the MCU
like at all they would occasionally
offhandedly reference oh yeah that guy
with a magic hammer like once and like
Chitauri tech showed up like once and
but they they tried to very much do
their own thing but the idea of having
these feel like spin-offs from the
movies that's kind of a level of
integration I think a lot of us were
hoping for and weren't getting out of
the other shows now that does this mean
that they're going to be great and all
and better than any of the other stuff
that was done on ABC or on Netflix well
no it's execution dependent it always is
but the the possibilities are kind of
impressive to me and especially because
you know one of the things with the
Netflix is you know they're they were
dealing with lower-tier characters with
actors that were pretty much unknown so
they they were they were doing a lot of
cost-cutting measures and even though
the characters that have been announced
to be getting their own TV shows on
Disney Plus have been what could be
considered the more supporting
characters you know they're not ones who
are leading their own films they're
still recognizable and these are still
movie actors and especially with someone
like Loki that is like legit iconic in
the movies that's like I said that's
aggressive and I think has if they use
if they use that standing as a launching
pad to do something interesting as
opposed to an excuse to just play it
safe because they don't have to be
daring cuz people are gonna watch
anyways that would be a disappointment
now I say that as if I'm gonna see these
I don't know if I am yet just because
you know I unprincipled I don't like the
idea of signing up for yet another
streaming service I'm already not on a
whole bunch of them that like friends of
mine are on I don't have I don't have
the CBS one I have CWC I don't have Hulu
I mean I've got Netflix and the only
reason that I have Amazon Prime is
because I have Amazon Prime for the
shipping and the streaming service
happens to come with it so that's just
purely coincidental so I'm not I'm not
huge on the idea of roping myself into
another service but at the same time for
the cost that it has and the lineup that
it has and knowing that it's probably
worth the price just for the percentage
of content that my daughter is gonna
want to watch alone it's probably worth
it
then again that
like and I always keep in mind what I
praise Disney it is never absolving them
of their monopolistic tendencies and
their copyright you know BS or any of
the other many many many many things you
can take issue with Disney as a company
so when I praise them don't think that
that means I'm endorsing that cuz I'm
not but they could have very easily just
held their catalogue of existing stuff
to ransom and made it and probably
gotten enough subscribers to to warrant
you know having the having the streaming
service
I mean honestly that's how the Disney
Channel launched back in the day because
like I'm old enough to remember and my
grandparents had it Disney was a premium
cable channel originally it had no ads
and there was very little that was
created specifically for it it was just
a handful of stuff by and large it was
just the Disney Catalog and they very
easily could have done the same thing
here especially yeah again understanding
what comes under the umbrella of the
Disney how long and how much they've not
only produced since they launched the
Disney Channel but also you know the
amount of stuff they acquired they just
they could have gotten away with just
holding that to ransom just saying you
want this stuff but to be doing that and
also like doing this big launch of all
this new stuff on the big franchises
that they that they acquired so that
they're not just sitting on them to to
take in the residuals it's it's a it's
yeah this is gonna be there's gonna be a
big push and they might actually pull
this off Wow I mean I say might like
they the other thing is Disney is Disney
can afford to take a loss
this for probably a couple of years
Disney can afford to play the long game
where they can launch I mean I'm not not
that I'm saying this is their plan but
they can afford to launch this lose
money on it and refine it over the
course of a couple of years until as
they start actually turning a profit on
it the company's not gonna sink if this
thing doesn't immediately make its money
back and I just checked my notes for
like the other stuff that's gonna be
like so like at launch there's obviously
a huge amount of the back catalogue it's
not absolutely everything because some
stuff they they still have licensed out
to Netflix or whoever else but as soon
as they get that back they're gonna keep
it anything that comes out from this
year and on that's just gonna go there
that's not gonna turn up anywhere else
so all the Star Wars movies rebels the
Clone Wars series those are all gonna be
on at launch Disney's 13 Films Signature
Collection the first 30 seasons of The
Simpsons the world according to Jeff
Goldblum I don't even know what that is
but now I want it 250 plus hours of
national geographic content the major
catalogues of films like Avatar Mary
Poppins The Rocketeer Tron a ton of
Disney Channel content things like Boy
Meets World ducktales Kim Possible
That's So Raven now within the first
year within the first year of launch
they're gonna have all the Pixar movies
and all the shorts oh there's the Marvel
series that I forgot the Falcon and
Winter Soldier so there's another one
again you know the movie characters the
what-if series I mentioned monsters at
work a Monsters Inc animated series and
Billy Crystal and John Goodman have
agreed to do it so like they are
throwing so much money around a series
based off love Simon a series based off
the Sandlot Star Wars the Clone Wars
season seven so a new season for that oh
my gosh and oh and another Star Wars
series beyond the Mandalorian there's
going to be a casseon and or series from
the character who's in rogue one
it's really
at again as much as it can make me feel
icky to praise Disney as a business they
know what they're doing this is a really
good launch lineup and again don't take
that as me going therefore it's the best
thing ever how big and how powerful and
how much Disney owns makes me
uncomfortable and Yuri are become more
uncomfortable with it and you kinda have
to find a way to balance these things
bring me enjoyment but the source makes
me uncomfortable this is a different
variant of that because some sometimes
yeah we talk about separating the artist
from the art when there are unpleasant
realities about creators behind things
that we like and I guess another variant
of that is separating the corporation
from the art jeez how did I manage to
end this on a sour note I don't know
I got a penchant for that lately in a
case the Disney Plus launched thing whoo
whatever your thoughts are on it drops
let me down in the comment let's talk
about it hope I just have to do buttons
links patreon P o box social media my
book etc etc etc links down below give
them a click or you also don't have to
I mean I'd always appreciate it but at
the end of the day you're the council I
just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]